non
car quand même les cadreurs qui
connaissent pas du tout l'émission a
aussi people et star le mec qui va dans
le couloir et la libye
je connais donc à l'émission tu vois ça
non mais franchement possible pas les
stars je le vois lui les tea
[Applaudissements]
party
le gars il va continuer comme ça ils
croient qu'ils habitaient spears y est
dans le coma
total a fait tomber son café
déconner oci toi mon vieux ccc vite
mais merde
travailler comme ça bon les chéris
d'il ya deux jours j'ai on nous a
quittés la disparition de jean paul
belmondo c'est bien sûr un événement qui
touche des millions de français on l'a
dit hier un hommage national sera rendu
demain selon les informations d'europe 1
oui le repas encore des informations
donc c'est vrai c'est beau et ça remonte
à un fort un repas papa forme sarandon
les français pourront se rendre se
rendre demain donc demain ou vendredi
ces savants tels les deux regarde et le
petit sujet de qui à mon avis sera
beaucoup plus complet que vous
pour tout l'état du territoire et la
tournée française et jean paul belmondo
mountain territoire
c'est dommage dans le monde oui je sais
dans le monde mais bon c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on leur demande s'ils savaient
faire des trucs whisky roma je trouve
c'est que à cet hommage national qui est
très protocolaire discours du président
de la république avec un drapeau bleu
blanc rouge sur le cercueil s'ajoute le
fait que des gens comme nous puis c'est
sale et ses manies vannes et m'envoie et
pas de réservation c'est lyon qui sont
les premiers ça je trouve que s'associer
nommage populaire al omari nationale il
ya mille personnes qui pourront aller
sur le fil au match il a lieu tous les
soirs à la télévision aussi il ya quand
même 15 millions de français qui ont vu
un film avec jean paul belmondo 2 l'ordi
entraîneur des marmailles fils à mon
immense popularité alors oui ya quelque
chose de très important il faut rajouter
c'est qu'à partir de 19h30 aux invalides
tous les français pourront se recueillir
devant le cercueil de jean-paul belmondo
ça avait été fait une première fois pour
jacques chirac ont leur nouvelle cette
fois ci ça c'est important parce que
nombreux sont ceux qui veulent se
recueillir devant le cercueil de
jean-paul belmondo alors il y aura mille
personnes effectivement sans réservation
sans réservation avec le pass sanitaires
dans les coursives et 700 invités par la
famille et l'elysée des personnalités du
monde de la politique spectacle et les
amis les proches aidant à monter j'avoue
être invité oui d'accord donc je vous
dirai pas si je suis là demain soir ce
serait également à bon merde ah oui non
mais c'est très important d'y aller
évidemment nous sommes on l'aimé
beaucoup et donc on y sera on sera à 7
cents à peu près dans la cour et il voit
tum attendez-vous à t'entraîner demain
je pense que demain tu étais bien sûr
excuses moi on demain avec un bien le
président a bien sûr la position
n'est pas la pesée vous castaldi si une
fois par mois par un huissier je
proposerai parce que mills est john jehn
il se fait poser
c'est alors que ce n'était pas le toit
il fait pas le poids demandé bas il
enlève son contrat
c'est ça a valu dansant rigoler lui peut
pas manger un truc quand il mange un
couscoussier la
moins chère coûte 100 kg chidiac
suivez
non mais selon toutes vos merdes et non
l achat alors à continuer ce les et ps
avec cette demande assez particulière de
l'âme la chanteuse qui s'apprête à
participer à la 11e saison de danse avec
les stars l'âme moi je la kiffe voilà
j'en dirais qu'on a eu un truc la pauvre
on l'a émise en choisissant chouette
nomination est la faillite
voilà prématurément et c'est vrai que je
l adore voilà là mais voilà quoi de
kenzy jeu l'adorent et elle ne souhaite
pas porter des tenues courtes et sexy à
cause de ses origines c'est ce qu'elle a
dit c'est la deuxième fois qu'on me
propose danse avec les stars je ne
voulais pas le faire parce que j'ai
toujours été très complexée par rapport
à mon corps de par mes origines on ne
montre pas son corps je me suis dit que
si c'était pour encore en faire faire
des problèmes dans la famille ce serait
non qu'est ce que vous en pensez
puisqu'il ya des gens qui ont critiqué
son univers de suite très favorable bien
sa déclaration à sa fidélité à ses
principes et au fait que la chaîne est
acceptée qui après les chants est
acceptée c'est très bien elle pourrait
être vraiment elle-même effectivement
elle sera je trouve épanouie et non
complexé bravo oui non moi je trouve que
c'est une sortie un peu floue et
alambiqué alambiquées oui parce qu'en
fait elle dit de par mes origines en
outre on ne montre pas son corps donc en
fait elle dit que les femmes maghrébines
ne montre pas son que leur corps à côté
de ça il ya d'autres femmes maghrébines
qui ont fait ce programme et qui ont
bien accepté de montrer leur corps donc
ça veut dire qu'elle stigmatise des
autres qui montrent leurs corps n'ont
chacun
vida et oui par exemple non mais il ya
là plein d'autres voyages by amel bent
qui l'a fait il ya wave tm qui va le
faire cette année par exemple la belle
parce que sa philosophie ça n'a rien à
voir mais voilà il j'ai sûrement fait on
ne sait pas si en fait elle le déplore
ou si elle elle est contente de le faire
et oui mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'elle dit c'est parce que je devrai
et après j'ai su complexe et après j'ai
des tatouages on compte qu'on a très
bien enfin la finance mais je trouve que
dans sa gueule et ça en fait c'est un
programme ou au monde voilà personne un
peu sans filtre très souvent les doigts
pleurer on les voit dans l'effort et
thomas sharks donc donc c'est bien elle
vient avec ses convictions elle le
déplore si la lgv à danser avec un
garçon elle elle met en avant ses
valeurs voilà c'est des films que je
vous avais dit
elle mais le porte drapeau de personnes
là en l'occurrence elle parle d'elle
elle même ses complexes et de deux de
ses origines etc elle dit pas il faut
faire comme ci ou c'est le lieu de faire
comme si elle dit pour moi ce qui me ce
qui me convient le mieux je me sens pas
bien dans mon corps par ailleurs j'ai
pas envie de laisser ma famille donc
voilà
les complexes les origines les tatouages
le cas parce que je pense que dans sa
tête aussi c'est un mix de tout ça mais
bon
on va passer à un buzz qui a été signé
par kev adams qu'est ce qu'on aime
beaucoup qui s'est fait un peu taclé
après une vidéo publiée sur les réseaux
sociaux vierge pas si vous l'avez vu il
a voulu parodier la polémique autour de
maeva ghana vous savez qui c'est fait
refaire la la la la la
c'est
[Rires]
à dire bye vacataires rajeunissement
positif en se déguisant et voilà et
voilà il c'est vrai qu'il a été
critiquée sur les réseaux sociaux va
nous dire ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'on peut encore rigoler sur les
réseaux sociaux je vous soutiens samuel
faille salue les parents voilà une
petite vidéo pour vous dire que j'étais
chimie biologique est le meilleur et je
me suis refait le fia ou voilà le 8 ou 9
g le fiel fin de 821 il est
magnifiquement fiom je les adore et ben
voilà le sifflement tnsm parc naturel
protégé quoi c'est à dire il ya des
animaux en voie de disparition div voilà
je vous fais des bisous et mieux le
fioul alors je me suis fait je me suis
refait l'océan il émane et suspensions
voilà qu'adams dérape et choc la toile
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce
que ça vous a choqué patricot oui et non
mais ça me choque créer une polémique à
cause de ça en fait on peut plus rien
posté sur les réseaux sociaux sans se
faire insulter qui est madame si les
humoristes il fait ça pour détendre
l'atmosphère en plus il entend bien je
crois que les candidates et les rites et
donc il fait pas ça pour l'humilier il
fait ça pour rigoler de la situation et
je pense c'est une fausse info parce que
j'ai pu son fion dernièrement
moi je soutiens kev adams là-dessus
également parce que franchement d'abord
pardon mais de la vidéo de la jeune
fille c'est une vraie suscité un
certaine envie de se moquer gentiment
bah oui mais lui il a aussi le droit en
tant qu'humoriste de se moquer dina et
moi je pense qu'il avait raison pas moi
je les adore mais là franchement c'est
un dérapage
a même tony tony l'envi tout est une
pâte
on s'est dit que la limite c'est est ce
que c'est drôle ou pas et logiquement
c'est pas drôle c'est qu'ils n'ont
laissé là que ça fait rire les gens
aiment votre jean objectivement un crime
je n'en sais rien je n'ai pas fait un
sondage ont été sortis dans la rue et la
limite
légale ça fait peur dit à la femme elle
me fait pas rire en tout cas
j'ai pas trouvé ça drôle et je trouve
qu'il n'aurait pas dû faire ça voilà
c'est le finnois moi je trouve ça
marrant mais en revanche porte est porté
en dérision ce que maeva a dit je le
répète pardon à tous des routes je
n'aurais peut-être pas fait parce qu'en
fait maeva cia le fond et la forme et en
profiteront
[Musique]
derrière il ya là des gens
le
effectivement revenir de la forme
importe
au niveau du fond c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet complexe beaucoup de fils un
sujet très tabou donc c'est bien au
final qu'elle ait parlé de ça parce que
tu penses qu'elle avait mieux
parce qu'avec l'essor du porno et ça bon
c'était l'émission d'hier mais je tenais
à le dire il ya plein de filles qui se
posent des questions là-dessus de mêlée
19h56 où on va faire appel à quelqu'un
qui est dans l'émission depuis ces
villes a peut-être pas remarqué nicolas
pernikoff la
[Rires]
vulve ou d'autre chose qui
s'est passée
très inquiet pourquoi de cette sur
réaction par rapport à ce sketch par
rapport à cette parodie parce que je
veux dire aujourd'hui on est comme dans
un pays de liberté liberté d'expression
nature et l'attaquent a été d'une
violence je sais pas si vous avez vu sur
les réseaux sociaux mais t'es dur les
gens ont été très violents envers le
coach de dire sarenza brice est d'accord
il peut faire des bons et des mauvais
truc maintenant c'est pas nous on a jugé
que rien faire
mais ça y est tu tu peux tu peux plus
péter santé le voisin qui vient sonner
chez toi
d'amélie au moins on sait où est son
fion
je n'arrête pas s'il n'y a passé que
c'est une incitation à la
pédopornographie
lui avait fait une parodie de
la maraude y ait de très bons bouchées
salées merci à bas alors voilà bah voilà
voilà deux poids deux mesures souvent
lorsque cavale âme c'est notre pote
voilà donc je ne connais pas et
d'ailleurs il me fait pas rire d'amitié
donc alors qu'à madame c'est notre pote
effet paris on à refaire kev adams et 9
des votes mais me fait pas rire mais là
je trouve que cette parodie est très
bien
ben tu peux mais
beaucoup alors que madame ce qui vous
fait énormément rire
on va parler de meghan markle ah oui ils
apprennent alors apparaît qu'ils vont
peut-être se réconcilier avec hot lap
le couple aurait demandé ce samedi 4
septembre d'urgence une réunion avec la
reine ouais ouais ouais grande écoute il
demande une réunion avec leur belle mère
mais oui c'est là c'est parce que la
reine n'a pas encore vu la petite bah
oui elle a pas vu encore l'aval à
fabuler des bêtes non canton qui
voudraient officiellement présenté le
hénaff 22 jours maintenant mais
je pressens des tout seul alors je
t'explique tony parce que c'est que
meghan markle et le prince harry ont une
fille est et leur mère la mère du prince
harry et l'a pas vu parce que il est
alité permet
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est une demande qui aurait dû
choquer auprès du palais regardez
regarde
l'ambiance est glaciale depuis l'annoncé
du retrait de megan est arrivé le choix
du couple est radical il renonce
purement et simplement à son titre au
royal le couple a lâché une bombe en
accusant la monarchie de racisme
watts il faut vraiment c'est quoi une
image symbolique là où de faire comme
les deux frères côte à côte avec la
duchesse de cambridge c'est une image
qu'on n'espérait plus et qui est sur nos
écrans autre nouvelle aujourd'hui la
reine elizabeth à 95 ans mais
apparemment son petit fils harry n'a pas
souhaité rester en angleterre pour fêter
son anniversaire avec elle a ri et megan
avait demandé un rendez vous avec la
reine pour qu'elle découvre en france
son arrière petit fils ce serait la
première fois que megan revient en
angleterre qui viendra pas encore décidé
s'il allait leur proposer de rester
jusqu'à noël
alors c'est le bal des hypocrites
pourquoi est ce honnête cette émission
oui pourquoi est-ce que megan et harry
se précipitent au chevet de la reine ils
veulent présenter lily bête qui disent
même qu'ils veulent peut-être y aller à
noël alors qu'ils boycottaient c'est
parce qu'il ya un sondage qui vient de
paraître en angleterre qui est
dévastateur pour utiliser c'est
historique seulement 26 % des
britanniques apprécient mégane et
seulement 34% après si harry n'ont
jamais leur popularité n'a été aussi
basse ils se disent c'est mauvais pour
les affaires comme par hasard ils
veulent se réconcilier
c'est de l'hypocrisie c'est bidon alors
pour une fille sont meilleures
oui bonsoir oui non je pense que la
reine elle fait surtout ça pour se
rapprocher d'harry parce que harris son
petit chouchou de quoi qu'il arrive avec
megan elle n'apportera jamais dans son
coeur on sait qu'elles peuvent pas se
blairer
jédir tu ne peux pas te bats contre
l'amour